اسرائيل لا تتخذوا مجموعه من العقوبات بحق
منفذي العمليات وعائلاتهم ترامب يقول انه
قادر على انهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا خلال
ساعات وزيره المصريه سابقه ابن سمع اصواتا
تامره بارتكاب الجريمه هذه الاخبار وغيرها
منقلها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
بعد عمليتي اطلاق النار في القدس
واللاتيني اسفرتها عن مقتل سبعه اشخاص
وجرح اخرين كشفت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
المصغره او الكابنت كشفت عن مجموعه من
الاجراءات العقابيه بحق منفذي العمليات
وعائلاتهم وسائل الاعلام افادت بان
الكابنه قرر اغلاق منزل منفذ عمليات القدس
خيري علقم على الفور تمهيدا لهدمه وحرمان
عائلات ممثلين عمليات من الحق في التامين
الوطني ومزايا اخرى اضافه الى رفض منح
بطاقات الهويه الخاصه بسكان القدس لعائلات
منافذه العمليات كما شملت القرارات ايضا
تسريعه وتوسيع نطاق تراخيص الاسلحه
الناريه للاسرائيليين لاضافه الى تعزيز
الاجراءات الامنيه في المستوطنه
اعاده دونالد ترامب الى تصدر حديث وسائل
الاعلام والسوشيال ميديا مجددا وذلك بعد
تصريحات قال فيها انه قادر على انهاء
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه خلال اقل من 24
ساعه الرئيس الامريكي السابق قال في منشور
على شبكته الخاصه 2 سوشيال قال اذا انه لو
كان حاليا في منصب زعيم البيت الابيض لكان
بمقدوره انهاء الحرب بشكل سلمي باتفاق او
بصفقه وليس بارسال ملايين الدولارات من
المساعدات الى كياف اضافه ترامب ان الحرب
في اوكرانيا قد تؤدي الى حرب عالميه بسبب
الاجراءات الامريكيه في اشاره الى تصرفات
الرئيس الحالي بما يتعلق بالازمه
الاوكرانيه
في اول تصريح لها منذ خروجها من منصبها
تحدثت وزيره الهجره المصريه السابقه نبيله
مكرم عن جريمه القتل التي تورط فيها ابنها
في امريكا مبرره حدوث ذلك بتعرض ابنها
لمرض النفسيه وفي مقابله عبر فضائيه
القاهره والناس قالت مكرم ان اصواتا غريبه
امرت ابنها بلقتل وانه كان يعاني من امراض
النفسي مشيره الى انه قرر وقف الحصول على
الادويه لايمانه بامكانيه التغلب على
المرض بنفسه واضافت ان وقفت تلك الادويه
يؤدي الى انتكاسه مفاجاه يعود المريض
بسببها لوضع اسوء من الاول لافته الى ان
ابنها كان يجلس بين زميليه من الضحايا
فاقدا للاراده والادراك وارتكب الجريمه
دون ان يدري ماذا يفعل
في حديثه اثارت ضجه واسعه في مواقع
التواصل خلال الساعات الماضيه فضح كتاب
جديد وهو جريمه سرقه نفذها نجم دفاع
مانشستر يونايتد ريو فيرديناند داخل مقر
الرئاسه الروسيه ووفا لكتاب كيف لا اكون
قويا للاعلاميه الرياضيه في بي بي سي
اليكس كوت فقد تبين ان النجم الشهير اخذ
خلسه ملعقه من على طاوله اثناء اجتماعه مع
الرئيس الروسي بلادي في الكراملين اثناء
فعاليات مونديال 2018 الذي اقيم في روسيا
مشيره الى ان ريو جعلها تضحك حينما كانا
في طريق الخروج وذلك عندما فتح يده ليكشف
لها انه اخذ ملعقه صغيره كتار من الكرام
وفي خبرنا الاخير تمكن الباحثون من انشائي
روبوت صغير جدا يمكنه الذوبان والتحرك
وايضا التحول الى جسم صلب مجله ماتر اوضحت
ان علماء في جامعه هونج كونج الصينيه
اخذوا الجاليوم وهو معدن يتمتع بنقطه سهار
منخفضه وقاموا بدمجه مع جزيئات مغناطيسيه
لانشاء الروبوت مشيره الى انهم تمكنوا من
تعليم الرباط الحركه ومن نقل الحموله خلال
التجارب وذكرت ان بامكان الروبوت تجاوز
العقبات وتسلق الجدران في خطوه تصلط الضوء
على كيفيه استخدامه في العمليات الجراحيه
[موسيقى]